Bitte schön.
Danke.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Sista ist mein Name.
Ich bin der Sistaererstin auf dieser Station.
Ich würde gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen,
sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mich.
Mir geht es nicht so richtig gut.
Okay.
Bevor Sie mir über Ihre Bescheide erzählen,
würde ich am Anfang einfach eine Frage stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Nicole Meier.
Nicole Meier.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen,
den Namen langsam beachten?
Ja.
N-I-C-O-L-E.
Nicole.
Und Meier mit M-A-I-E-R.
M-A-I-E-R.
Okay, Frau Meier.
Was ist Ihr Nagelbohren?
Ich bin am 15.7.65 geboren.
15.7.75.
Wie alt sind Sie?
57.
Doch, im Juli werde ich 58.
47.
Okay.
57.
50?
Hoffe ich doch, ja.
Ich hoffe, ich habe nicht falsch gerechnet, ja.
Können Sie mir bitte fragen,
wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ja, ich bin 1.63 und wiege 71 kg.
71 kg.
So, Frau Meier, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, ich habe so unangenehme Bauchschmerzen
und die werden eigentlich immer schlimmer.
Und ja, mir ist auch schlecht.
Und ja, was mich tatsächlich jetzt ein bisschen erschreckt hat,
ich habe gestern einmal gesehen,
dass da in meinem Stuhl lang, dass da Blut drin war.
Und dann hinterher habe ich einmal gesehen,
das war gestern einmal ein bisschen und heute auch,
dass das so ganz schwarz war.
Das fand ich ein bisschen unheimlich.
Ich habe gedacht, ich muss jetzt doch mal dringend mich hier bei Ihnen melden
und mal gucken, was da los ist mit mir.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie gerade Herzrasen oder ein schlechtes Gefühl,
wie ohlmachtig geworden?
Nein, nein, nein, ich habe nur kräftige Bauchschmerzen,
so Oberbauch sind die.
Okay, ich würde gerne noch einmal fragen,
Sie haben gestern Stuhl im Blut gesehen
und heute...
Blut und Stuhl?
Blut im Stuhl gesehen
und nur einmal.
Das habe ich nur einmal gesehen, sonst ist mir das nicht aufgefallen.
Aber das ist ja schon so, dass man da so ein bisschen Streck bekommt
und dann war das eben hinterher einmal,
dass das ganz schwarz aussah
und heute Morgen war das auch.
Heute Morgen, ha ha.
Heute Morgen hau...schwarz.
Einmal...gestern einmal,
Blut im Stuhl gesehen,
heute Morgen schwarz gesehen.
Okay.
Okay, dann können Sie mir bitte
Genuaer beschreiben,
ihr Stuhl,
wenn Blut in Ihrem Stuhl geht,
dann war es...
hal Blut, hal Rot.
Vielleicht glaube ich eher nicht so hell.
Ja, nicht so hell.
Okay, heute Morgen, aber war es...
dunkel.
Wie war die Menge gestern Abend?
Bitte was?
Die Menge, die Menge ihres Stuhls.
Ja, das ist ja nie so viel.
Also ich muss irgendwie mehrfach am Tag auf die Toilette
und dann...also...
normal.
Mal mal 2, 3 Mal
und dann ist das nie so viel.
Mhm, verstehe.
Und Sie haben Bauchsparsen.
Können Sie mir bitte sagen,
ja wo Genuaer Schwarz sind.
Ja, so oben, eigentlich so...
direkt unter den Ritten würde ich sagen, ja, da fängt es schon an
und es drückt so ganz heftig
und nach dem Essen wird es besonders schlimm.
Mhm, nach dem Essen.
Ist es in der Mitte oder eher in der Rechte?
Ich würde sagen in der Mitte, eher in der Mitte.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Angefangen hat das so ungefähr vor 3 Wochen
und dann habe ich das erst gar nicht so ernst genommen,
aber weil auch am Anfang nicht so schlimm waren die Schmerzen,
aber jetzt werden die ja immer mehr
und jetzt ist es manchmal so,
das kann ich kaum noch aushalten,
also richtig heftige Schmerzen.
Hatten Sie auch früher eine Hebäche werden?
Früher habe ich so etwas noch nicht gehabt,
nee, ich kenne es gar nicht.
Mhm, okay.
Die Schmerzen verschlechtern nach dem Essen haben Sie gesagt,
sind die Schmerzen da?
Ja, eigentlich sind die schon jetzt die ganze Zeit da,
aber nach dem Essen ist es halt besonders schlimm.
Ich fühle natürlich dazu,
dass Sie mich gar nicht mehr trauen, etwas zu essen.
Und dann esse ich nur so leichte Sachen,
das, was ich mal ein bisschen reiß,
mit heller Sauce oder ich mache mir sogar mal Haferbrei.
Manchmal habe ich auch nur Teel und Zwieber,
weil ich gedacht habe, der Bauch tut so weh.
Aber ja, jetzt irgendwie geht es gar nicht mehr.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wie viele Schmerzen sind auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Ah, die sind schon so im oberen Drittel,
vielleicht so bei 7 oder 8.
7 oder 8.
Okay.
Schmerzen Sie in andere Körperteilen aus?
Nee, ich ist das auf den Bauch beschränkt.
Sind Sie eher drückend, pulisierend, stehend?
Drückend, drückend.
Sind Sie das beschreibt, das richtig?
Okay.
Ich habe mir gesagt, dass wir nach dem Essen,
aber eher in der Nacht oder tagsüber haben Sie mehr beschwert.
Nachts versuche ich ja zu schlafen.
Manchmal ist man ja auch so müde,
dass man drüber einschläft.
Aber wenn ich morgens aufwache, sind die Schmerzen jetzt auch da.
Tagsüber, würde ich sagen, sind Sie schon mehr.
Haben Sie etwas ausprobiert, um mir nicht meistens zu nennen?
Ja, ich habe versucht, mal eine Wärmklasche draufzulegen.
Das tut ja eigentlich immer gut.
Aber da hatte ich jetzt auch nicht das Gefühl,
dass das so wirklich viel hilft.
Natürlich habe ich das,
ich habe verminste und schwarze Tee getrunken.
Aber ja, das ist richtig stolz.
Nicht ganz gehofft.
Okay.
Frau Meyer, haben Sie ja erbrochen?
Nee, mir ist nur schlecht, aber übergeben muss ich mich nicht.
Und es schmeckt mir halt nicht.
Nein, es ist jetzt gar nicht schlecht.
Ich habe mal 2 kg abgenommen in den letzten Wochen.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich immer so ganz nett.
Aber trotzdem, das ist eigentlich nur,
weil es mir so gammelig geht,
weil ich so wenig gegessen habe.
Sie haben in Englisch 2 kg abgegeben.
Ja, in der Zeit, seit es losgegangen ist,
in diesen 3 Wochen, würde ich sagen.
Habt ihr genommen?
Haben Sie viel wahr?
Nein, ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich an, ich nicht, viel bricht.
Sie brachten ihr viel wahr, nichts zu missen.
Okay.
Aber Sie haben nicht zufrieden?
Nein.
Nein, ich nicht.
Also, wenn ich erst mal schlafe, dann schlafe ich auch nicht auf.
Okay.
Das heißt, Sie haben auch keine Schlafstörungen.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe keine Schlafstörungen.
Okay.
Sie haben auch keine Schlafstörungen.
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich keine Schlafstörungen.
Das ist mir jetzt schon länger aufgefallen.
Seit wann?
Ach, das ist bestimmt schon ein paar Monate.
Hab ich aber nicht so ernst genommen.
Seit wann?
Das ist auch nicht immer, sondern halt, ja, wenn man mal was besonders
Herzhaftes gegessen hat oder ja, wenn man mal gefeiert hat oder so, ja,
dann hat man hinterher so mal.
Ab und zu von Wasser essen.
Du hast es schon verstopft.
Leider sind Sie unter du hast es schon verstopft.
Normalerweise, nein.
Okay.
Ja, hat die Farbe ihres Üries verändert sich verändert.
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Mir ist das nur mit dem Schulgang aufgefallen.
Okay.
Frau Meier, leiden Sie an Konchnerkplan kommen?
Ja, in meinem Alter, da hat man schon so das eine oder andere Zipperlei.
Wobei eine Sache habe ich schon ewig lange.
Ich hatte eine Schuppenflechte.
Schuppenflechte.
Das habe ich schon seit jungen Jahren.
Und wenn es zu schlimm wird, muss ich da Cortison Salbe nehmen.
Und manchmal muss ich auch tatsächlich dann Ibuprofen nehmen,
wenn die Schmerzen zu unangenehmen sind,
so dass ich vielleicht nicht arbeiten kann oder so.
Dann habe ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck und ein bisschen hohe
Blutfettwerte.
Ich habe das schon seit 9 Jahren festgestellt.
Und dann nehme ich halt auch irgendwie ein paar Medikamente.
Und hoffe, dass das damit in Ordnung ist.
Hyperalipidemie und ja.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ja, das eine.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt.
Und dann nehme ich noch sowas für die Blutfettwerte.
Das ist ein Statin.
Aber weiß ich auch jetzt nicht, wie der Handelsname ist.
Okay.
Ist Ihre Mitkommanzin dabei?
Nee, die habe ich tatsächlich zu Hause liegen lassen.
Das habe ich vergessen.
Stimmt.
Da müssten Sie vielleicht bei meinem Hausarzt anrufen.
Ja, okay.
Wir können Ihren Hausarzt anrufen und infagen.
Nehmen Sie nur eine Medikamente gegen Blutdruck.
Ja, ja.
Nur eine Medikamente.
Okay.
Kann es von April sein?
Ja, ich meine, das heißt anders.
Okay.
Wie viel Milligramm ihr preferiert, nehmen Sie ein.
Ich habe das schon seit 9 Jahren festgestellt.
Okay.
Wie viel Milligramm ihr preferiert, nehmen Sie ein.
Ich habe das schon seit 9 Jahren festgestellt.
Ja, meistens 800.
800.
Brauche ich aber auch nur eine.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ihr Profi eingenommen?
Ja, bestimmt irgendwann in den letzten Monaten,
ja, letztes halbes Jahr.
Ich hatte vor einem halben Jahr meine Trombose im
linken Bein.
Ja, da hatte ich auch ein bisschen Schmerzen.
Da habe ich das dann auch gemacht.
Aber...
Danke, mein.
Wo das vor einem Jahr, vor halben Jahr, Diagnose sitzt.
Vor halben Jahr, ja, genau.
Wie ist das behandelt?
Ja, ich habe dann Strumpf getragen.
Und dann habe ich so ein Blutverdünner.
Aber das ist jetzt schon wieder abgesetzt.
Wieder abgesetzt.
Warum ist das abgesetzt?
Bitte?
Warum wurde es abgesetzt?
Na ja, nach 4 Monaten haben wir das abgesetzt.
Okay, vor 5 Monaten.
Nehmen Sie Aspirin ein?
Ne, normal nicht.
Haben Sie im Monat 5, in Irambäin?
Ne, das ist eigentlich gut gegangen.
Alles gut gegangen, okay.
Dann würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, so richtig eine OP war das nämlich.
Ich hatte hier einen Steine.
Und dann hat man mir so eine Handleiter-Schiene gelegt.
Und seither habe ich da keine Probleme mehr.
Das ist schon 6 Jahre her.
Und diese Handleiter wurde wieder heros getroffen.
Ja, ja, doch, ja.
Es musste, okay.
Sie haben gerade keine Probleme.
Warum nicht? Das ist gut wieder.
Okay, gut.
Dann wurden die Situationen behandelt?
Damals?
Ja, ich glaube, ich war 2 Tage zu überwachen da.
Bisher war ich nicht im Krankenhaus.
Okay.
Pramoyer, ist es bei Ihnen allergimne kommt?
Ach, eigentlich nur so etwas, was alle Welt hat.
So braunes Pflaster kann ich nicht gut vertragen.
Da kriege ich immer so ein Picklchen.
Und da muss ich halt weißes Pflaster haben.
Sie bekommen Yukrais?
Ja, ja, dann kriege ich so ein roter Pünktchen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Unverzüglichkeit gegen Lebensmitteln?
Nein, eigentlich konnte ich bisher immer alles essen und trinken.
Deswegen wundert mich, dass ich jetzt so Bauchschmerzen habe.
Keine Unverzüglichkeit haben Sie.
Sind Sie durchgeimpft?
Ja, eigentlich bin ich gegen alles,
was man so haben kann.
Die Impfung und Corona bin ich natürlich gegen Corona.
Ich bin natürlich gegen 3-mal-Gift.
Ich bin jetzt hier ein paar Infos,
ich muss ja über Ihre Gewohnheiten.
Sie?
Ja, aber nicht doll.
Also nicht mal ein Päckchen am Tag.
Also vielleicht so 10, 15 Zigaretten am Tag.
10, 5 Zigaretten am Tag.
Seit wann schon auch Sie?
Das habe ich gar nicht so früh angefangen.
Ja, so ungefähr 20 Jahre.
Seit 20 Jahren.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol kann man jetzt nicht sagen.
Ich trinke schon abends gerne mal so ein, 2 Bier oder im Sommer,
wenn es warm ist.
Das hat mir jetzt die letzten Tage auch nicht mehr geschmeckt.
Aber ansonsten trinken Sie jeden Tag ein, 2 Bier.
Ja doch, eigentlich schon regelmäßig ja.
Zum Abendbrot und dann noch zum Fernsehprogramm.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich,
das ist eine Flutinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Drogen?
Nein, habe ich noch nie was zu tun.
Ja, aber kein Kontakt.
Frau Meier, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Buchentlärmung.
Danke, Lerin.
Das sind Proteste aus dem Hintergrund.
Müssen Sie gucken?
Müssen Sie hingehen zum Kind gucken?
Ich versuche, wir können weiter.
Danke.
Buchentlärmung.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Keine Leitlichen, das sind Stiefkinder.
Stiefkinder?
Hat mein Mann mit in die Ehe gebracht.
Nur ein Stiefkinder.
Sehr gut.
Die sind jetzt aber auch schon groß.
Ja, ich würde das fragen. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, die sind fast 20, also 17 und 19.
Okay, sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind gesund, ja.
Okay, sehr gut.
Wie leisen Sie unter Stress am Arbeitsplatz?
Ja, da war natürlich jetzt schon eine anstrengende Zeit wegen Corona,
dass dann Schließungen waren und dass man nicht wusste,
wie es weitergeht und dann so Saisonbetrieb.
Aber eigentlich nicht besonders, würde ich sagen.
Aber in letzter Zeit wegen der Corona-Lage
hatten Sie auch Stress können.
Ja, klar war man nicht, ich wusste, wie sich das alles entwickelt.
Okay, gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Krankheiten,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Keine Seite.
Also meine Mutter, ja meine Mutter,
die hat Probleme mit den Beinen.
Die hatten offenes Bein und man vermutet,
dass die Gefäßverschlüsse hat.
Schaut sie?
Ja, die hat auch geraucht, ja, ja, ja.
Sie hat Brauchabein dann?
Möglicherweise ist das so etwas, ja.
Ihr Vorzeichen?
Der ist schon lange gestorben.
Der hat in den Verkehrsunfall und ist dabei ums Leben gekommen.
Das tut mir leid.
Wie alt war er?
Da war der ungefähr so alt wie ich jetzt, also Ende 50, ja.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Meuer, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich wüsste natürlich gerne, woher das kommen kann,
dass ich solche Schmerzen habe.
Und dass man dagegen tun kann?
Ja, ich vermute bei Ihnen ein Magengeschwür.
Aber das ist nur eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Deswegen muss ich das für körperlich unterzuholen.
Und bei Ihnen ein paar andere Unterzuholen,
dünch für einen, sobald alle Befunde für ein Leben können
und eine Verdachtdiagnose haben.
Muss ich denn in einem Krankenhaus bleiben?
Ja, Sie müssen in einem Krankenhaus bleiben,
weil Sie haben gestern ein Hotel,
wo man Schwarzschul zu gehen.
Das kann auch eine Blutung hinweisen.
Deswegen müssen Sie bei uns überwachen bleiben.
Aber ich habe noch nicht die Unterzuholen dünch geführt.
Deswegen können wir uns entscheiden,
ob Sie bei uns bleiben und nach Hause gehen können.
Das ist gut.
Gut, dann war es sich jetzt.
Ja, okay.
Dann guten Tag Frau Oberarztin.
Ich bin gefühlt, aber zockig hier.
Wollen wir erst mal fragen, ob da jemand eine ergänzende Frage hat?
Vielleicht will ja noch jemand etwas dazu sagen.
Wir sind ja nicht in einer echten Prüfung.
Sie müssen ja nicht mit den 20 Minuten klarkommen.
Heute drei Minuten,
als ich das verbracht habe.
Das sind ja nur meine Minuten, Dr. Günness.
Sie hat viel gefragt, aber ich habe auch viel erzählt.
Gut, da hat noch jemand Fragen zu dieser Frage.
Vielleicht habe ich das nicht gehört.
Sie haben gesagt,
dass die Trombose, linken Bein,
eine Medikamente ungefähr vier, fünf Monate eingenommen.
Aber ich habe die Namen der Medikamente nicht gehört.
Die Frau hat keine Ahnung von ihren Medikamenten.
Sie hat wahrscheinlich einen Blutverdöner gekriegt.
Irgendein Heparin.
Aber sie weiß das nicht.
Das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen blöd.
Im Fall ist beschrieben,
dass sie sechs Monate vor sechs Monaten eine TVT hatte.
Ich erzähle mal,
dass man bei der TVT sechs Monate hinterher antikoagulieren muss
und Strom zu tragen.
Aber sie hatte hier einen anderen Arzt,
der hat ihr nur vier Monate die Strom höre.
Und das Makumar gelassen.
Ich möchte einen Ratsschlag machen.
Ich möchte einen Ratsschlag aufmachen.
Ein Frau, die ich ja noch hatte,
hat die Stiefkinder eine Krankheit haben.
Das vielleicht sie schon in der Flügel fragen.
Das ist eine starke Stich-Move.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob sie ein Stressfaktor auch hat.
Da gibt es keine Blutverbundungen.
Das ist sicherlich ein guter Hinweis gewesen.
Ich hatte auch noch nie in den ganzen Fällen.
Ich hatte noch nie Stiefkinder.
Sonst hat niemand etwas.
Wir machen weiter.
Ich habe einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen
und würde gerne diese Patientin vorstellen.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob sie sich für mich aufgenommen haben.
Natürlich.
Danke schön.
Frau Nicolae Maya ist eine Patientin,
die sich bei uns wegen der Bauscheprogramm dient
postprandial, epigastrieral Bauschemersen vorgestellt hat.
Frau Maya ist 57 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 1,63 groß und 71 schwer.
71 kg.
71 kg schwer.
Die Patientin hat ihre Schmerzen erst rückend
und mit 7,6 auf der Schmerzskala beurteilt.
7 bis 8.
7 bis 8, ne?
7 bis 8 haben sie gesagt.
7 bis 8.
7 bis 8 beurteilt.
Die Patientin hat angegeben, dass die Rechimersen
postprandial verschlechten
und sie leidet unter Übelkeit
ohne Vomitus.
Seit wann hat sie die Schmerzen?
Seit wann?
Vor 3 Wochen.
Seit 3 Wochen.
Seit 3 Wochen hat sie angefangen.
Sie hat seit 3 Wochen die Schmerzen.
Die Patientin hat mitgeteilt,
dass sie auch Appetitlösigkeit hat
und in den letzten 3 Wochen
hat sie 3 kg abgenommen.
Sie hat ausserden berichtet,
dass sie gestern Abend im Stuhl
anglutt gesehen hat
und heute Morgen Schwarzstuhl abgesetzt hat.
Was ist das Fachbedrück?
Melena.
Heute Morgen Melena.
Gestern Abend,
haben sie zu dem Thema,
heute Morgen Melena,
hat.
Sie hat mit der Schmerzen
die Schmerzen,
Ja, die Präzise hat.
Als Vorerkrankungen hat die Patientin seit Junger Alter Psyriasis
sie wandert dagegen Cortison Salbe an.
Die Patientin leidet an Artidriallehipartoni und Hyperlipidemie seit neun Jahren.
Sie nimmt dagegen Statin und Antihipertanzi, die deren Namen sie nicht weißt.
Vor sechs Jahren hat sie Wudeir wegen Nephrolitiasis
Harleinzer Schiene geleckt.
Deswegen wurde sie zwei Tage im Krankenhaus behandelt.
Die Patientin hat vor halb Jahren
die Patientin hat vor halb Jahren
Medikamente, Angenomen, deren, dessen Name, die nicht weiß.
Sie nimmt aus der dem Geigen, ihr Rechimersen, Ibuprofen,
als 100 mg, by bedarf.
Die Allergie, die Patientin hat Geigen, Brownes, Flester,
Allergie, das aus der sich durch exantem,
Sie hat keine Unfertschäglichkeiten und sie ist dreimal gegen Corona geimpft.
Die Patientin braucht seit zwei Jahren,
10, 15 Zigaretten am Tag, das macht 10 und 15 Packung Jahr.
Sie zwingt jeden Tag ein, zwei Bier und hat keinen Kontakt mit den Drogen.
Die Patientin ist in Buchhand deren von Beruf, sie ist verheiratet,
sie hat zwei Stiefkinder, die 20 und 7 Jahre alt sind.
17.
Nicht sieben, sondern siebzehn.
Siebzehn Jahre alt sind.
Sie hat es erwähnt, am Arbeitsplatz Stress zu haben.
In der Familienanalyse ist es erwähnt, dass die Mutter, die Mutter Piafika hat.
Und ihr Vater ist mit 50 wegen Verkehrsunfall gestorben.
Anhand der Analyse, vermute ich bei der Patientin ein Ukusventrüceli,
die aufgrund Zigarettenkonsum, Alkoholkonsum Stress
und Antikorglaneinnahme verursacht wird.
Verursacht wird.
Was wäre differentialdiagnostisch möglich?
Die Patientin hat außer der Maginblützung, obere Maginblützung,
als differentialdiagnose Magin-Karsinom, Söphagus-Karsinom in Betracht.
Gut. Was machen Sie denn jetzt für Untersuchung mit dir?
Bei der Köpferlische Untersuchung würde ich die Patientin am Anfang
gefraut, ob sie eine dynamische Instabilität hat.
Aber ich würde immerhin die Vitalparameter überprüfen,
die Patientin an der Monitor anschließen.
Ich werde alles abholen, ob sie Herz-Rhythmus-Störung oder Tachikardi hat.
Ich würde auch bei der Parapation den Abdelmann abtasten
und Epigastriallbereich abtasten, ob die Patientin Druckdolentischung
am Epigastriallbereich hat.
Aber in diesem Fall sieht es nicht so notvermäßig aus.
Wenn die Blutung chronisch ist, ich würde gerne sehen,
ob die Patientin auch Eisenmangel-Anämie hat.
Was machen die da, wo hat es noch?
Bei der Blutung haben die Blutgazanalyse und die Hemmunglerin
schnell zu sehen.
Was noch?
Wegen der durchgemachten Trombose.
Das wäre interessant, auch noch eine Schulprobe zu untersuchen.
Das wäre dann die Untersuchung der Wahl bei dieser Patientin?
Das ist entscheidend, ob die Patient eine notvermäßige Therapie braucht.
Das ist nicht.
Wenn die Patientin hemodynamisch ist, können wir in den nächsten Tag
eine Östephalobastriolloskopie planen.
Das ist ein sehr guter Method.
Das ist eine eine andere Art des Untersuchungsmethodes.
Was kann man da unter anderem mitmachen?
Andere Diagnose?
Was würde man noch für ein Untersuchungsverfahren anbinden?
Ultraschalluntersuchung?
Das auch.
Was würde man mit der Ultraschalluntersuchung ausschließen können?
Die andere Pathologie, die andere Organpathologie,
im Abdoman Bereich, oder zum Beispiel Karcinom,
Östephaloscinom, Maginkarsinom.
Danke, das war es.
Ich wollte heraus, dass es im Magen ist.
Was wollen wir da wissen, was da drin ist?
Ein Schnelltest?
Ja, das ist ein schnelles Test.
Wir wissen, dass die Patientin eine Helikobakterpipri-Positivist ist.
Natürlich, die Nehmen-GWP-Probe ab.
Und auch die Üremiden-Rias-Test, die Königin-Bestie-Ppatientin.
Die Helikobakterpilori, eine Urzehe für diese Magingeschmürist-Gastitöse.
Was ist positiv, welche Behandlung kommt dann infrage?
Die Trippeltherapie ist in diesem Fall injiziert.
Es sind zwei Antibioteterapie und Protonpompa-Hemmarsch.
Ja, super. Gut.
Und wenn es negativ ist, was wäre dann?
Wenn es negativ ist, ja.
Also, wenn es negativ ist?
Dann ist es ein Schmerz-Mittal-Bedingte.
Das ist eine Magingeschmürist.
Ja, und wie würden wir das dann behandeln?
Ja, diese Schmerz-Mitten absetzen und Protonpompa-Hemmarsch einleiten.
Und was ist mit Alkohol und Rauchen?
Ja, diese Lebensveränderung muss unbedingt zur Frage kommen.
Man verhakt sich auf Zigaretten und Alkoholkonsum,
kann die Beschever den Lindern und spült eine größere Rolle bei der Behandlung.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt haben die Prüfer noch zwei Fragen gestellt.
Was spricht für die Diagnose des Ulkos Ventricoli?
Was spricht für die Diagnose?
Die haben drei Punkte besonders ausgegriffen.
Ulkos Ventricoli, Druckschmerz bei der körperlichen Untersuchung,
Druckschmerz-Heftigkeit an den Alpigastidiumbereich?
Nein, ich meine es jetzt aus der Anamnese.
Drei Punkte aus der Anamnese, die in diese Richtung geführt haben.
Ja, Schmerz, Zigarettenkonsum, Alkoholkonsum und Schmerzmitteltherapie.
Ja, und das hat die Patientin beschrieben, wann kommen die Schmerzen?
Oder wann sind sie verschlechtert?
Postprandial Schmerz.
Genau, und das hat sie noch beschrieben?
Sotbrennen hat sie noch beschrieben.
Das weiß ich auch.
Ja, die Ulkostridien.
Sotbrennen, Oberwarschmerzen und Postprandiale auftreten mit der Schmerz.
Das wären so Hinweise für diese Diagnose.
Haben die jetzt gesagt?
Gut.
Dann die Gastoskopie.
Klar ist die Methode der Wahl.
Was ist dabei das Risiko?
Bei einem, und welche Komplikation gibt es bei der ÖGD?
Ja, Magenschleimhautverletzung oder Magenschleimhautverletzung, Perforation.
Perforation, genau.
Gut.
Noch viel geschmiert.
Ja, also ich habe keine weiteren Fragen mehr.
Ja, dann bin ich gespannt, was bei Ihrer Untersuchung rauskommt.
Halten Sie mich bitte auf dem Laufenden über die Ergebnisse.
Und wie es der Frau Meier in den nächsten Tagen geht.
Ja?
Danke schön.
Ja.